Stephen and Kevin this question is
mainly for you Warren if you feel
strongly about it though you can give an
answer as well
I'm gonna say this not giggle during
this question but who do you think pooed
in the P bucket oh yeah
come on Stephen I mean it's clearly me I
think it's like the I'm like the one
that can't walk very far to go to the
actual
yeah I do remember that I do remember
that scene and everybody's like come on
what and I'm just like
[Music]
it's it's it's it's honestly it's got to
be you or it's got to be misty Misty
would do it just to piss yeah just to
piss everybody off yeah yeah just to
cause a little something might have been
both of us these are the questions
you could throw a name in there if you
want
yeah
I got a dinner
oh no she's impulsive very impulsive a
very challenging character to track one
thing I've been curious about since
season one because we don't get to
experience this moment with him what do
you think it was like the very first
time he found her journals and actually
read them what was his initial reaction
oh I bet it was one of the more
nerve-wracking experiences for him once
he realized
what he was reading and he could have
been halfway into it before that with
him he has moments of clarity where
he'll catch up to the moment
I I'd like to think that eventually he
started casting himself as a character
in the journal
as if he were there and how he may have
staved off this tragedy or this
emergency or saved them if only he'd
been there to you know just typical
egotistic all kind of lionization of
himself
you
you really messed it up I love how you
called that egotistical and as you were
explaining it my mind was like oh that's
oh that's sweet he just wanted to see it
though well I think there's that there
is that one drives the you know you can
your ego can drive you to actually help
the group uh and then I think that's a
great setup for him in terms of how he
actually handles survival in uh season
two
the reality of who he is yeah there's a
lot of complex stuff going on for that
family right now in non-spoiler
territory still Stephen for you a lot of
the characters in the 1996 portion of
the show flat out like voiced their
opinion on how they feel about what
lottie's doing
he doesn't really though so where do you
think he stands on it like I know he
doesn't follow Lottie but how angry is
what she's doing making him I I think
there's two elements to it there's one
that you know if he was in a normal
State I think that he would be doing a
lot of eye rolling along with the the
people that are not necessarily part of
her group
um I think he's much more of a practical
guy and you know he has some of his own
Wilderness experience from you know
hunting when he was younger and all that
kind of stuff so I think he's much more
like let's map this thing out let's
figure out you know a practical way of
getting out of there
um the flip side of that is that of
course he is slowly but surely being
ostracized from the rest of the group so
I think there's also an element to it of
what's the point like if I if I did say
anything nobody's listening to me anyway
so why even waste my breath you know
like gotta conserve some energy at this
point it's it's just a useless futile
exercise to voice an opinion at some
point I am nervous for him I'll tell you
I am nervous I'm nervous for all the
characters he's like high up on my
concern list right now he's number one
on my list for sure believe it yeah uh
I'll squeeze in one more non-spoiler
question for fun this is going to put
you guys on the spot creatively but I I
need you right now to answer this
question so I can sleep at night what
did the bun say to the hot dog
do you two even know what I'm referring
to nope I want to hear it okay Warren
don't answer I want to hear their
answers I was like wait that does sound
familiar but I literally have zero zero
elections yeah of what that is the Buns
say to the hot dog fill me oh God no
this seems like you asked you gotta
knows I don't know we're gonna need to
edit this part out
um I have no idea
um I really enjoyed just being so
flummoxed by my own
riddle that I couldn't come up with once
that was fun this is a joke that you
like say in the script and we just know
never again what the hot dog say to the
bun you know it's probably easier but he
goes with what's the bun say to the hot
dog to try to lighten the moment and
it's like what and he stays you know and
he's got nothing admittedly I cheated
and Googled it and wrote down the first
answer that came up and it is kind of
Sweet let's relish our time together oh
there we go that does work it is a dad
joke it's perfect for him